We're starting the top of the news with some bottoms.
Good Housekeeping reports that there's a $30 pair
of butt-sculpting leggings that claim to plump your rump.
Seasum leggings are all the rage on TikToK.
Number one on Amazon's Leggings for Women.
And do they really yum your bum?
Well textile experts say, "Yes!"
The secret is in the ruching
which is a special curve seam
on the back that makes your butt look curvier.
Ali, I saw you working out on Instagram.
Are you ready to juice that caboose or what?
I am not a girl who believes
in all those smoke and mirrors.
My feeling is "this is what I got".
You know what I mean?
I've been married for a hundred years.
I'm not gonna make any secrets.
These are real, this is real, nothing's padded.
Goodnight, Gracie.
(audience laughing)
You know, Lee Harris, who is the star brilliant stylist.
We're such good friends, we've worked together for 20 years.
He would give anything to get me in a pair of Spanx.
That's all he ever wants to do
is squeeze me into some tidy shape-shifting forming things
that I won't do it, that poor Lee.
I'm sorry, but I just can't.
I get it, every job I've ever had.
I get four pairs of Spanx in my trailer and big padded bras.
Yes.
And I go, "All right, I'm not enough, apparently."
Lee would pour me into a tube of toothpaste
and reshape me if he could.
Yeah, yeah.
(audience laughing)
So, you're a "no" to these too, these leggings?
I can't breathe.
Well, I don't know the leggings.
I'm intrigued, but for me, it's about the fit and the feel.
I don't care.
I can't try to look a certain way
and be uncomfortable about it.
I completely agree.
Okay, your story, Ali.
All right, so next, Drew,
people show their love in mysterious ways.
And now Glamour reports,
Brooklyn Beckham and his fiance, actress Nicola Peltz,
have said, "I love you," by swapping teeth.
(throwing up)
(laughter)
Nicola had their wisdom teeth plated in gold
and now they're wearing them on necklaces.
Have you ever traded teeth with the lover?
(audience laughing)
No, but it just hearkens back
to the Angelina--
Billy Bob.
The blood.
The vials of blood on the red carpet.
I remember that was a real story.
Yeah. I've never traded parts
but I was proposed to once, not by George Stephanopoulos,
by a boyfriend who said was very nervous
that he had a polyp and he said,
"Will you check it out?"
And I was like, "I'm an uptight wasp.
"I don't wanna check anything."
And he laid down on a towel
and there was an engagement ring sticking out of his butt.
(audience laughing)
I said, yes!
And then I said, "Is there a necklace to go with this ring?"
(laughter)
But that was like as far as I got to sort of swapping stuff.
Yeah.
I once dated an artist Fabrizio Moretti
for almost six years.
And I love him so much. We're still friends, obviously.
And he is an artist,
so he would make me these like a zoetrope machines.
And he was so fantastic.
And so I went to a doctor and got an X-ray of my heart
and then put it on a light board.
So it was a piece of art for him.
That's romantic.
That's not icky, like my story.
(laughter)
No, but it's like, "Just give me funny."
You know?
That's my motto.
Yeah.
So when George proposed very romantically
on an Island in Greece,
I was like, "No, okay."
(laughter)
Well then this story is so perfect,
'cause I do wanna know your thoughts on this.
Good sleep has been hard to come by this year.
And many sleep-deprived people who are coupled up
are trying something we call a "Sleep Divorce".
HuffPost reports said,
"This is when you and your partner agree
"to sleep in separate rooms to get a better night's rest."
And experts say, "This is a totally healthy solution.
"And it shouldn't have a stigma attached
"because better sleep means better moods
"and clearer communication the next day.
"And it can actually help your marriage."
Ali, thoughts.
Well, I have been married for 20 years
and my husband gets up at 2:30 in the morning to GMA
and I sleep with him every night.
I go to bed with him at 8:30 because I wanna stay married
'cause he leaves at 2:30.
But I have a lot of friends that--
Because of snoring issues or tossing issues,
I don't wanna get him in trouble.
But the man that miced me said that he flips around a lot.
So he and his significant other are separate.
And it seems to work out really really well.
So I have no problem with it.
I don't either.
I'm just like, "You know what?
"Who said these are the rules?"
Exactly!
Like maybe you do you and do what's best for your home.
Yes, if I wanna sleep with other people, I should be--
Oh, I'm sorry, that's not what we're talking about, right?
(laughter)
No, but I do think that
if there are issues with getting enough sleep,
sleep is the most important thing.
So, fine, go sleep in the guestroom.
And by the way,
you can have sex in other rooms during other times, so.
Right, you know what my motto is, Ali?
Live and let live, man.
Yes.
You wanna sleep in separate bedrooms?
Do it.
Yes.
Sick of everyone judging each other
Me too.
Your story, Ali.
All right, Drew.
So you are a beauty brand CEO and I love your stuff.
Thank you.
and you love cute stuff.
So fasten your seat belts for this.
PopSugar reports,
"Makeup company, HipDot, has teamed up with Peeps
"and their Peep-inspired shades for your papers
"just in time for Easter."
And check out these little squishy chick sponges.
How cute are these?
No, they're painful, it's so cute.
Oh, they're so cute.
And by the way I have teenage girls
that just gouge my makeup.
Yes!
And to give them these instead of eggs
that are filled with caramel, which I end up eating,
is a better basket treat, I think, for Easter.
Ali, you're absolutely right.
I've already been stressing about the Easter egg hunt
and too much chocolate.
Because if couples are worried about sleeping,
put children on tons of chocolate and see where that goes.
Yes.
Oh, hi, Easter bunny, how are you?
That is one delicious bunny.
Bunnies actually.
And look at these Peep colors.
I know,
I love it.
How fun would it to be
have like a pink poppy or blue shadow?
People go gaga for this because it's fun,
it's imaginative.
People need to have more fun.
I totally agree.
And I think collabs is a perfect way to do it.
I think that Flower Beauty should team up
with a candy company too.
Well, I think you just gave me the best idea
which is I'm gonna plant a bunch of these
on the Easter egg hunt.
Well, exactly.
Or even place them in your Easter egg basket.
Done.
My girls will go crazy over this
and I'm taking these home.
I don't care who these belong to.
Do it, do it, do it!
Ali, I love getting to do this with you.
I love getting to do it with you.
Please let it be the second of so many more times.
Let's see what the paycheck says,
and maybe I will just rest.
You are my kind of woman,
I'll sleep with you or apart, whatever you want.
Okay.
All right.
Ali's podcast "Go Ask Ali" is streaming now
on iHeartRadio or wherever you get your podcast.
(bright music)